imagine calling to you from the darkness
the voice of someone you loved who
recently died you're terrified but you
can't ignore the hypnotic promise of
seeing them again you venture outside to
find the source a fatal mistake
this is the lure of the Nishi hailing
from Bengali folk tradition these cruel
monsters are also known as nishidak
which roughly translates to call of the
darkness or the call of the night the
lies between demon spirit and deity are
often blurred in cultures of the Indian
subcontinent the clear good versus evil
dualism seem more commonly in the
Western Hemisphere doesn't exist in the
same way the Nishi Falls firmly into the
malevolent end of ghostly beings and
teaches us a lot about the culture it
comes from
I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is monstrum
the Nishi dock is one of many boots or
ghosts in Bengali tradition there are so
many types of ghost stories in Bengal by
Bengal I mean the country of Bangladesh
as well as West Bengal in India the
state we used to all be one big region
of course after the partition of India
in 1947 when we achieved our
independence we became two separate
countries but our stories and our
folklore Traverse those borders of both
nationality religion class and the like
that's Dr sayantani dasgupta assistant
professor at Columbia University and
children's Nya author but the Nishi is a
slightly different malevolent entity
than the rest of Bengali ghost lore
Tales of these harmful Night Spirits are
prevalent in small and Rural Villages
they pose a deadly threat to those who
wander at night Nishi call out to
Peaceful sleepers in a familiar voice
usually a deceased loved one
one story I've heard about the Mishi is
that they are a kind of
disembodied ghostly form that can call
you mimicking the voice of a loved one
so for instance if at night walking by a
deserted bamboo forest you were to hear
somebody calling your name somebody very
familiar for instance an aunt or a
beloved cousin calling you maybe even in
a nickname that only they know don't
turn around
because it may be an issue trying to
trick you out of your spirit while the
monster adopts the voice of someone
their victim knows these malevolent
Spirits aren't necessarily the ghost of
the person's voice they are adopting the
complex nature of Nishi is reflective of
the spiritual Community from which these
monsters originate the very idea of a
ghost becomes additionally complex in
cultures where spiritual practices
center around the ideas of reincarnation
ancestral worship and Karma like
Hinduism
in Hinduism the subtle body or second
body is the part of a person that is
reincarnated into another physical form
the deceased corporeal form must be
completely obliterated so the subtle
body can move on hence the preference
for cremation this also means Bengali
ghosts don't have grave sites to haunt
bengalis and particularly Hindu bengalis
have the notion of rebirth and
reincarnation and so Bengali ghosts are
sometimes perceived of as recently
deceased people who have not been able
to enter the cycle of reincarnation but
sometimes Bengali ghosts are actually
thought of as creatures monsters of
Their Own Kind a kind of different
species in and of themselves now Nishi
or nishidak are not exactly among this
category of spirit because they exist in
a far more Sinister and disembodied form
unlike a lot of other Bengali ghosts
an exclusively malevolent Spirit like a
Nishi can be the result of incomplete or
improper funerary rights the deceased
fails to transition their subtle body
and thus cannot be reincarnated and
since no one wants more Nishi protecting
and executing cultural burial rights is
Paramount if we see the call of anishi
as a way the spiritual body continues to
link itself to the physical body the
corporeality of the voice becomes
particularly interesting what if a Nishi
cannot be heard does it cease to exist
or does it become even more ambiguous
and ominous
the fact that the Nishi can steal or
mimic the voice of a deceased loved one
seems particularly threatening in this
sense it suggests we cannot fully trust
the dead or our own ears in such a way
that it will cause our demise which
quite frankly is pretty terrifying yet
the call of the Nishi is hard to ignore
Only The Chosen victim can hear the
nishi's hypnotic voice interestingly
these beings cannot call out to you more
than two times so Superstition dictates
that you never respond to anyone calling
your name at night unless you hear it
three times
those who do fall under the influence of
a Nishi fall into a trance and will
follow the distant voices to a remote
area
and these nighttime strolls are
dangerous if one is unable to break the
nishi's influence they disappear
presumably killed
while the Nishi can call to or even grab
their victims visual details of the
monster tend to be vague in some
accounts the Nishi appears as a shadowy
or indistinct form resembling the
person's voice they mimic in others they
are an all-white Misty entity with a
vaguely human shape the ambiguity
highlights its mutability and lets the
imagination run wild
in one story translated by Dr sujitra
samanta anishi directs its attention to
a little boy the Boy shared a close bond
with his aunt who helped raise him he
would lovingly catch his aunt's favorite
freshwater fish to eat when she died
suddenly the boy was too devastated by
grief to perform his aunt's last rights
he would not eat or speak becoming ill
himself exorcists were brought in
amulets and charms applied but nothing
worked one night the boy woke suddenly
claiming he heard his aunt's voice
calling to him
soon rumors spread of a figure sitting
in a tree at a nearby Pond then after a
heavy Monsoon rain a midnight fog
encased The Village
the boy again hears his aunt calling to
him begging him to come catch her fish
so he sneaks out of the house and begins
to collect the fish but then he spots a
figure in the trees fear brings the boy
back to his senses and with much effort
he is able to run but he doesn't get far
before a long arm snatches his basket of
fish and the boy falls into a dead faint
three days pass before he regains
Consciousness everyone warns his mother
to keep a close eye on the boy for next
time he might have his neck broken by
the Nishi but the monster is Relentless
and wears the boy into this
he walks straight in Sinking below the
surface his body is dragged up in the
fisherman's next
elements in the story give insight into
some cultural practices and taboos
it isn't far-fetched that the boy's
Affliction was treated with a variety of
methods including exorcism belief in
spirit possession and malicious sorcery
is common in this region even today
although controversial
some religious sites are known for
exorcisms but face increased scrutiny in
the modern day an Afflicted person might
make a pilgrimage to one of these
temples or shrines to remove any
negative spiritual or Supernatural
ailment
policy reforms and growing awareness of
mental health challenges have made these
temples and shrines divisive arguing
that they encourage Superstition and can
do more harm but others counter that
they offer a form of traditional
alternative healing that should not be
dismissed or demonized
like many other night Spirit Stories the
victim wanders off and dies at night
because of this Nishi influence is often
said to be responsible for a particular
trance-like State sleepwalking
fun fact I used to sleepwalk as a kid
one night my parents found me knee-deep
in our pool something I have zero memory
of death by sleepwalking is rare but
injuries aren't uncommon perhaps the
Nishi serves as an explanation for the
strange phenomenon and helps the
community stay alert and keep
Sleepwalkers safe nishidak's stories are
also told to make sense of horrible
illnesses so let's say there's a child
who for no explainable reason without
any treatment is getting sicker kind of
wasting away in a family you might say
that the Nishi has called away their
life force so the notion is that maybe
somewhere else in the village or
somewhere in the locality a wealthy
family with an ill child of their own
has employed a tantric or a magician of
some sort to wander around the
neighborhood saying a particular magical
Mantra and carrying around a hollowed
out green coconut in which they hope to
trap the essence the soul or the life
force of a healthy young person and give
it to this ill one so in a community
with high rates of infant mortality and
childhood illness stories like those of
the Nishu duck may have been a way for
families to make sense of what was
completely undistanable and happening
before their eyes
let's go back to the creepiest part of
this monster and the thing that
literally defines it the disembodied
voice in the night
people have been trying to understand
the phenomena of the disembodied voice
for quite some time from exploring the
validity of religious Communications to
assessing Clairvoyance even now we look
for answers in both the secular and the
scientific as technology and
urbanization continue to evolve and
literally bring light to the darkness so
do the stories of the Nishi but that
doesn't make them any less important as
a Bengali immigrant daughter to the U.S
Bengali folks stories stories about
flying horses princes and princesses
evil serpent Kings and even monsters
like the carnivorous drooling Rock cush
and of course the ever of present
Bengali put
were literally what connected me to my
cultural roots these were stories that
were told to me by not only my parents
but my grandparents oral stories are
critical to communities throughout the
world and I think particularly to
diasporic communities who are raising
children far from their Homeland folk
stories monster stories ghost stories
are a way to connect young people to
their Origins to their ancestors and to
their sources of cultural belief these
stories are deliciously frightening
sometimes to listen to but they're also
deeply meaningful somewhat ironically
given the nishidox dangerous call in
speaking and hearing their stories we
preserve their importance
the deceased corporeal Community stay
alert and keep safe Walkers safe oh my
God I started it and couldn't stop
myself you know Nishi Docs